[Music]
some major announcement today just
wanted to let you know that this next
intro this parody of Taking Back Sunday
may not make sense until or unless you
know that irrefutably ilon Omar married
slashed consummated with her brother
that's a
fact
enjoy
[Music]
your lipstick is collor don't bother Al
lot I know exactly what goes
[Music]
on Omar married her owned by a logical
brother wish this was a joke but I'm
completely serious
yeah
some people did something I will just
say I have no interest in commenting
about my personal
life and will you tell all your friends
Omar married her sibling this song was
super necessary the song was super
necessary and will you tell all your
friends El married her sibling this song
was super necessary this song was super
necessary let's go
[Music]
don't bother trying to explain it to me
I know exactly what goes on with your
bro how about I'm here fact checking
yourself how about I'm here fact
checking your the details covered to get
a vis you your brother will you tell all
your friends Omar married her sibling
this song was super necessary this song
was super necessary and will you tell
all your friend Mar hering song was
super necessary this song was super
necessary let's
[Music]
go I why are you dodging this
question very stupid
question you understand what no comments
just in case you claim the song's
misinformation here's a pick of the
marriage certificate yeah no one never
asked and you will never tell we know
the truth is that you honeymoon with
your bro just in case you claim the
song's misinformation here's a pick of
the marriage to forg yeah s will never
ask and you will never tell them we have
all the receipts that show you Shar the
same name just just in case you claim
the songs information here's a cck of
the marriage certificate yeah no one
never ask and you will never tell them
we know the truth is that
your is super gross in
all you to wet and
consumated Unholy macony only thing
worse than headful is terroristic and
just you two wet and
consumated Unholy matrimony your grand
kids will look like they're from the
movie Del you to and
consumated on holy matrimony your grand
will look like they're from the
[Music]
[Applause]
movie remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign sign
up for mug club today at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub for $89
annually join the fight at
louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
today got a damn good news for y'all
this is the organic story of already
successful men who transformed their
priorities right in front of your eyes
it's our first podcast for uh Steven
Crow network but you going to get the
first 30 minutes for free well 15
minutes let give them 15 minutes you
know what give them 10 they Patriots
Yeah oh Trump theming alone is 300
M do like a plantation on they all had
all them funny B
TI right now so this is heart attack
Samy and as they began to speak out more
they were penalized more videos were
demonetized that's a
he club with us St
forever never never sign
up it's on our
website this is unpr white people y'all
can figure this out yeah show me the mug
Club show me the mug club they're going
to be exclusively members of the mug
Club Army a full weekly show for the
first time Hodge twins uncensored hey
come on man that's it that's the
[Music]
[Applause]
promo
[Music]
I glad to be with you hey the C the
camera's a little higher today because
uh I need to have better posture sure
yes and when the camera was lower I was
I was doing this a little bit like you
rang remember back in the day when the
studio used to be in my garage the
camera was over here because we and and
for a period of about three months I was
like I have a spasm in my upper right
back and like is it because do you
you're not doing this all day are
you yeah I guess so so thank you to man
we upgraded the technology yes we did we
upgraded the technology hey speaking of
upgrade yep Hodge twins starts here
today their new show you can go to uh
lc.com Club use the promo code hodg
twins to let them know that you love
them yeah now we have them we have Brian
K Nick depalo every day you are you get
our show tomorrow along with Alex Jones
you're going to get another hour of our
show here today the investigative unit
none of it happens without you you are
the Army we are funded by viewers like
you and we don't just say that while um
Burton Ernie collect a homo fed check
so they weren't gay they were
experimenting no oh saying they're
getting money from the federal
government it's the one thing that
everyone hates about Mitt Romney I liked
about Mitt Romney it's the only thing I
liked about him he was like I'm going to
defund I'm going to defund PB Ben Romney
wants to take money away from Big Bird
it's his only redeeming
quality so all right we have a lot to
get to today uh yes we will be talking
uh about the war quick update on that
and I'm sure you've been inundated with
it um but we have a Gerald knows things
segment Because he believes that Trump
can save Israel he believes he's a
messiah I don't what uh but I want to
talk about I don't did you know this the
stud came out not too long or I I get I
don't even want to say study also a
chemical analysis that the co variant
the one that's giving you the sniffles
right now also artificially created or
engineered in a lab yeah according to a
Japanese analysis I have no idea who but
it just seems irrefutable and everyone
just skimmed past this I skimmed past it
did you guys know comment below did you
know that we obviously knew about the
the first lab leak right but Omron so I
just SK like oh yeah okay I was creating
a lab and then I dug deeper wait wait
wait Ron I had that like last
week so we'll be talking about that
because it's not just about Israel and
Hamas though I do think we should kill
every last one of them and if you agree
you can hit the like button all right
number two Captain Morgan how are you
doing well I'm feeling better good you
don't like that nickname do you I don't
mind Captain Captain Morgan no you just
you can't go over the top of a nickname
because then people won't want to give
you one you like have to play a little
koi i i l Capitan and then when you hear
him I guess you hear this
[Music]
music it's a new selection wow that's
fantastic you can go and see him I don't
have his plug in front Messi Jess it's a
Messi Jessie Messi Jess's aberin in
Washington Friday October 13th that's
this oh it's a Friday October 13th oh no
it's going to get even more messy it's
going to be so messy by the way I
figured out what this place is what they
got a bartender there named Jesse
Parkinson's
oh that's right that's like when theying
you just tell me they bring Randy Travis
out on stage now and I love Randy Travis
but like all strokey what you're saying
that they just they do his music and
he's just sitting there yeah he's just
kind of
like my love is deeper than and he's
like C Brown singing he's like aren't
you black I used to hate
that
black oh have you guys ever seen that
we'll bring that up on mug Club the uh
the Randy Travis video in the cop
car when he was and I feel bad I love R
by the way you have a good set of pipes
let Josh know that's not a bad Travis
hey thanks I can only do Randy Travis
that's it is that it I sing I can do
Lady Gaga covers I can do Britney covers
yeah but only in Randy Travis R Oops I
did it
again I'm off the
[Laughter]
deep he was in the passenger seat of the
cop car he was he was drunk and and and
completely naked he's like do you know
who I am I'll kill you like and but
they're like yeah but you're Randy
Travis you know it's he's in the
passenger seat yeah he's like when I'm
through with you there'll be Three
Wooden Crosses on all right I'll he's
like I'll bury you deeper than H Randy
you're not going to kill anybody when
I'm through with you they'll be Digging
Up Bones shut the hell up I'm going to
put you in the B I'll be
quiet sorry we got off forever and ever
amen okay I'm done I'm sorry look look
we're going to put you in the drunk tank
well I guess I'm going back to a better
class of L
okay zip
it yeah we got a show yeah we got a show
we got
show all right uh well hey this is right
on Q before we go into anything else uh
fedman remember him ah yes oh yeah
speaking of idiots the guy the guy the
guy who makes you long for George
Zimmerman speaking of
stroke I said it nicer he
offered he used to a clean slave yeah
this is the this is why this is why
Vivic and Rhonda santis they don't want
to come out with because it's live
they're like when can we do it we do a
live show like well we don't want to do
it live well okay I don't blame you so
fedman just offered his refreshing
opinion on a late night show past his
bedtime about government and I don't
think he realizes that he's saying what
he's saying you all need to know that
America is not sending their best and
brightest you know to Washington
DC You Know Hoodie with iPad facing
him says you are you literally just
can't believe like you know these people
are making the decisions that are you
know determining the the government here
it's it's it's actually
[Music]
scary representative Federman uh no
argument here I don't think so yes
actually best point you've made
yet I mean even like we were talking
about Randy Travis after he has a stroke
they have someone else come out and do
it he's basically a Chuck-E-Cheese
animatronic thing you know but fedman is
actually making decisions looks like
Grimace though yes he does is there an
excuse for not wearing pants can I can
we get something does he have like
something wrong with his legs I don't I
think it's just a big uh I think it's
another Ploy from Big Academy Sports
he's just showing off his calvs yeah
he's showing off his Cavs he's just he's
just always ready to ball yeah exactly
he's just goes in place he's placed by
Street rules yeah always always it's
called hoop let's not joke about it Cavs
are the hardest place to Mas us
now so is that why you're hiding
yours
so long week it's Thursday hey that's
right it's chat Thursday we'll take more
of your chat so you get to let us know
how disappointed you are in US
yes so the co the co you guys may have
forgotten about the co uh rightfully so
comment below the last time you had it
or if you've had it multiple times many
people I know have had it multiple times
I don't even think I checked check
anymore I'm like it's I I mean I have
I've been able to avoid getting sick you
know which is really tough to do with
with young Twins or Petri dishes it's
been about 5 months which is a good run
yeah promise this is Pine it's a soft
it's going to have my knuckles in there
now uh in
August
the why are we everyone get have the
munchies why is everyone giggling today
you were giggling to the silliness of
denting the pine
like you knew it's Pine too that's great
it is well it is cuz I bought it I
bought it the first time in my desk
again back in the garage and it split oh
yeah that was too cuz were you knocking
I no I didn't realize you had to like
laminate I don't know anyone who works
with wood who's a woodworker they were
like yeah you can't yeah your desk of
course it's going to split like because
the studio because we have to keep it
dry for the equipment like a certain
like yeah it's going to split it's a
soft wood I was like oh yeah Pine is a
soft wood and what have you sure sure I
have another desk made of pine
yeah but yeah you put on a
varnish it's way cheaper you have an
idea how much the deaths are at these
other networks oh yeah so expens I think
this is like a couple hundred bucks it's
a big
thing so
in clip it it's a big
thing all right all right all right
let's talk about the deadliest virus in
human history so in
August Japanese scientists they released
these results and even I missed it so
I'm curious if if you guys caught this
we have all the references available in
the in the description go to lc.com um
they released these results of a study
regarding the evolutionary origins of
the Omron coid variant so keep in mind
Omron is really far down the like right
there was then they had Delta then they
had Omron I think we're on to another
one I think we're on yeah there was said
was going to hit us again but it didn't
yeah it's like Bond at this point it's
co tomorrow forever again keep your day
so before we get into the the results of
that study I want to get into it and
give it the attention it's deserve it's
it deserves say now I'm just thinking
about Pine now let's let's kind of go
through how we got here because the
gaslighting is so effective from the
left that some people I don't want you
to move on I want you to never forget
this I will say this and I'm curious uh
as to if you exp I I haven't ever seen
more people become conservative in my
life than Co so many people I mean
people back in my childhood who I would
never think would lean right because of
Co just the mask came off left said yeah
this is this is way too much and now
they have to dive into everything oh and
by the way before we talk about co uh if
at any point you see this when you're
watching on
YouTube that means that what we're
saying can't be said go watch un Rumble
anyway I don't know if we're allowed to
question co now on you we are elections
elections yes I think you can say
something about the lab leak which is
new okay all right we'll see good all
right so let's go back to then okay
we'll do a then and now and then we
actually have kind of like a then and
then and then now and when will then be
now no one knows anymore so fouchy
remember him he he insisted that Co was
a completely natural occurrence lab leak
you're a crazy person this morning Dr
Anthony fouchy is shooting down theories
that the Corona virus was man-made he
tells National Geographic everything
about the stepwise evolution over time
strongly indicates that this virus
evolved in nature and then jump species
as I've said many time uh many of us
feel
that it is more likely that this is a
natural occurrence as has happened with
saws K1 where it goes from an animal
Reservoir to a human fairly large group
of very well-respected evolutionary
virologists have examined
epidemiological virological geospatial
what data from Wuhan and have come to
the conclusion not definitively by any
means but feeling that it is much more
likely that it is a natural occurrence
from an animal to a human you notice he
just does what Trump does he but in a
lying way where he says other people he
goes other PE all these other
epidemiologists feel they seem to uh
like Trump was like look all the other
epidemi that's I would never say that's
what the best people tell me that's what
he's doing right there he does the same
thing only he lied about all it by the
way science isn't governed by consensus
it's an important tool it's determined
by truth it's science so someone was
right and the good news is a lot of
people were right at that point in time
time you think about this you were more
correct than Anthony fouchy if you
believed that it was from a lab leak
because let's go back to also then and
this brings us to I believe February
when Christopher Ray can't stand that
guy um confirmed at this point after you
were removed people lost their profiles
they lost their YouTube channels for
being a conspiracy theorist then it was
confirmed okay it all right you caught
us it's a lab leak the FBI has for quite
some time now assessed that the origins
of the pandemic are most likely a
potential lab incident in wuhong so here
you're talking about a potential leak
from a Chinese government controlled lab
that killed millions of Americans the
Chinese government seems to me has been
doing its best to try to
thwart and obfuscate uh the work here I
hope the new one is actually MH I hope
it's been created in a Chinese lab
because it'll fall apart in 6 months
that's true we also by the way we do
have exclusive footage confirming what
he said um now regarding the Omron
[Music]
release seems like we should have seen
the signs absolutely yeah going to be
rough so we have then then which brings
us to now this study from Japan uh
suggesting we have to couch so hopefully
I won't be removed that the Omron
variant did not at all have natural
Origins and they actually if you read it
uh they kind of they suggest it but they
say there's actually no way this could
have occurred in nature and um every
sort of metric that they have available
would suggest that it was bioengineered
so it wouldn't actually be able to
happen this way so they stopped short of
saying we know who engineered it but in
this study they say there's no way that
this evolved naturally this is this is a
new one which again like I thought okay
maybe at some point they were trying to
cover their asses this happens a lot
right sometimes people lie because they
make a mistake and people don't want to
admit they're wrong just there's a lot
of power in human beings their drive to
not admit that they are wrong that's why
we have the admonish button because we
know that we're not immune to it right
so I thought okay maybe it leaked from a
lab but they didn't mean to they were
trying to study viruses to see if they
could create some kind of create some
kind of antidote maybe a vaccine in
advance I understand that stuff goes on
then it got out and they said okay this
is going to look bad for us so let's
just let's blame it on someone eating a
bat I cannot see any justification to be
doing it now with new variants with
Omron what's I'm trying to rationalize
from their point of view how could
anyone justify after Co happened
continuing to engineer these viruses in
a lab it's like a vampire you know you
don't just become a vampire naturally
there's one then he bites you right is
that how it works I think I don't know I
got all conf from Twilight you might
have to have sex might be an STD I'm not
sure I think that's it follows I'm not
really sure but but then they created
the it follows prep you can't have a a
strain of a virus that didn't occur
naturally that occurs naturally yeah
exactly and now it's the it's the
variant yeah they lied to us from the
very beginning we knew this you know who
else knew this fouchy yes he knew that
he he lied about gain of function
research funding like Rand Paul called
him out on this in Congress did a great
job doing that but he knew the whole
time yeah the entire time by the way if
you are like you said going to study a
virus to see okay like can we make an
antidote in advance can we just see how
bad this could get so that we could be
prepared for it why partner with China
on this that's controlled by the Chinese
Communist party that eventually kind of
would like to take us out most likely
because we are the superpower they want
to be the superpower this doesn't make a
lot of sense to me yeah yeah I think
you're I I realized not the best partner
let me read some quotes from the uh the
study actually uh this is from the
Japanese that they say that the
formations of a part of Omron were not
the products of genome Evolution as is
commonly observed in the analysis we
have shown here is that the Omicron
variants are formed by an entirely new
mechanism that cannot be explained by
previous biology and knowing the way how
the SARS Co 2 variants were were formed
prompts a reconsideration of the SARS Co
2 Pand this is because it's coming from
the Japanese who are very polite yeah
that cannot be it cannot be explained so
did are you saying that this was created
in a lab
analis uh no happen in nature okay so
how did it happen no possible nature are
you saying saying that someone did it in
a lab no nature no possible nature are
you saying this is a bioweapon I don't
know I don't know no no I don't know no
nature they're being polite about it yes
our previous understanding of all of
biology doesn't explain this and so
therefore we have no idea are you saying
well hold on a second are you suggesting
just because we don't have the answer it
still could have occurred naturally no
no no no no no no no these are the same
people that believe in Pokemon yes
exactly well it's real I'm not sure as
to the their theology
I'm pretty sure they worship it exactly
I caught a Mewtwo back in Pokemon Blue
that was a big deal in the schoolyard
it's huge huge so how do you think the
United States government uh let me I
want to be careful because we're on
YouTube you think the US government knew
that Co actually came from a lab and do
you think that they do you think that
they have known that Omron has come from
a lab or do you think Japan got there
first though they have a habit
no let me give you a quick update here
uh on the war and if you're watching hit
the like button it helps with the
algorithm on YouTube on Rumble they want
you to think that we're all
dead ah L war in Israel is obviously uh
continuing we're now in it's I believe
fifth day yeah sixth day is an Arnold
movie it's a lesser Arnold not a great
one yeah stop whining it used to be one
not whining it used to be one of his
lesser ones until
Maggie Maggie Maggie oh
no not again
um so uh I warn you again kids shouldn't
be watching this show uh this is a PG-13
plus if you were watching this so that
you can be armed with information so you
can protect and serve your family and
Community um here's actually a montage
of uh you know Israel now retaliating
rightfully so in full
force
dur that last C I would have been
running instead of
like yeah talking almost does nothing to
bombs I think they were
praying yeah I think I'm pretty I heard
a lot quite a few I think they're legit
praying well one
does an interesting one to add
so look let me just be really clear here
I get that this sucks to watch and I
understand that there there there there
is always collateral damage right and we
will call out the deliberate targeting
of innocent people no matter who does it
but let's be clear after what happened
from Hamas against Israeli citizens
Israel has to respond at this point and
I just so we don't get confused with
this coded language um anyone out there
calling for ceasefire what ceasefire
means at this point ceasefire means
support for terrorism ceasefire uh means
[Music]
destruction ceas Fire ceas Fire come on
guys calm down ceas
fire you don't get to call a ceasefire
after someone's been brutally murdered
and raped they have the right to it's
it's it's return fire it's justi as
Hellfire so let me just give you a quick
and of course it's casualty uh reports
from from Israel they say that 100 uh
sorry um 1, yeah I guess 1300 now this
just changed even from this morning
Israelis have been killed 3,300 injured
200 kidnapped to Gaza um Hamas is
claiming
1,55 Palestinians have been killed
they're claiming 5, um 184 injured and
then something that obviously matters to
all of us American citizens are also
among the dead missing 22 killed 17
missing uh water power has been cut to
Gaza you probably know about yeah uh
that um there is a they're trying to
piece together they're trying to piece
together something I do think that
Israel may be underestimated the the
threat from Gaza there have been some
slow response Times by the way in Israel
uh at least there were during the
initial stages of the attack so this is
kind of what's been going on and then of
course Egypt as we've talked about hey
why don't you take him Egypt they've
closed their border completely to
fleeing gazin um they've bombed Israel
has bombed some airports in Syria um and
they're preparing for a possible ground
attack uh in Gaza that's kind of the
update I believe yeah that's troops are
massing there so things are getting a
little bit more fiery we'll see if they
actually go into Gaza with those troops
or not yeah that's just an update in
case you've missed all the references
are available at L credit.com I think
that those are the most important need
to knows we're going to discuss sort of
the difference in policies and
approaches with Donald Trump versus
remember same thing with the economy it
applies here with Israel you had eight
years of Obama
he had really three years of of trump
before you know they they engineered uh
engineered a virus in a lab to try and
you know kneecap him the last year and
then you're going to have another four
years of of Biden so we already saw what
happened with Russia and Ukraine Obama
Trump then Biden so now we see what's
happening with with Israel um you have
really really good comparisons you have
a really good control group but before
we move on to that we actually have a
live update uh again you support this
with with Mud Club um with our on the
ground correspondent in Gaza uh actually
right now Thomas
[Music]
finnean all right finigan it must have
been a long trip I I hope it was worth
it this time I Steven yeah wait uh where
are you Giza for the no we sent you
halfway around the world and he still
managed to screw Gaza F you're supposed
to go to Gaza the war Israel Palestine
is it ringing ringing any bells for you
anything uh now now that you mention it
uh it is pretty quiet around here I
thought they were on lunch break no no
they're not uh but I was thinking of
you I don't and I got you some of the
finest bedding in the world well okay
that's they are I have sheets though I
don't need a super and what's with your
voice are you sick finegan I had some of
the local street food it's too spicy but
this is where the my pillow guy gets his
cotton from I got you a full bed set
well those are the worst pillows in the
world unless do you want sleep unpacking
peanuts that's that is that what you
want yes yes I do I'm more angry over
that than you going to the wrong country
finnean I'm genu see what the return
policy is it's not good it's not a good
return policy I can tell you that this
trip is coming out of your paycheck
finnean wait when's pay day again all
right cut him Tim cut him Co
[Music]
man don't let that be a reason to not
join Mud Club okay not everything's
perfect those sheets look perfect though
I'll take them if you don't want them
Stephen if you oh it's my finest
Egyptian cotton really my finest cin
oh wa he hasn't been around lately
michell no he's been Hawking his wees
though on Fox oh good well look I
haven't tried his sheets his pill
pillows I wasn't they didn't work for me
I think somebody bought it it's a
personal preference it's a personal
preference yeah it is you like
now I like to sleep with
every night I have a have a
body pillow have you ever wanted to
feel like when you sleep like you're a
you're a pig you're a piglet you're
going to love my PO you feel like a
little piglet in SLO it's F oh you're
never going to have any it's the best po
you ever had you're going to put it
between your legs and it's just
whatever I bought it before he started
advertising on conservative I just
bought it because of the box I'm like
someone someone this oddl looking
putting himself on the box obviously he
is overcoming such a fantastic product
like there there must be something in
there that makes this all make sense and
I it felt like Styrofoam it was the
other
way just like to think he's so
passionate about pillows and slippers
slippers he has for sure he he's had
them for a long time well Gerald's had a
pair for a long time no I've not are
they the finest slippers they are the
finest flippers I just I like and by the
way you're going to love it cuz it's
made in America from the finest Turkish
what I think he's a decent guy just to
be clear I just don't just you know he's
just fun to make fun of yeah he just
well it's just I just don't like the
pillows so obviously there's a lot
developing in Israel and um now Donald
Trump has been president Trump has some
people call him former president Trump I
call him some people call him former
president Trump some people call him
sitting president I call him sitting
president uh he's been brought into the
mix and uh because he's very passionate
about this and so am I but every now and
then he just has to get he has to take
the Limelight it's time for J nose
things you wanted to be a star Gerald
and everything that goes with it
including terrible Stingers thank you
very much I thought it was a great sting
yeah shut up Josh and thank you for your
thank you for your service so we
appreciate it but when you start paying
for The Stingers then you can you can
decide what they are that is a fair
point all right well look on Wednesday
Ronda STIs uh his campaign tweeted out a
message with a video uh looking at
Donald Trump and actually trying to
smear him saying that he was uh saying
some really mean things before we go to
this can I just say I warn you I don't
use the term trigger
warning but Mike Pence is like you're
going to see some comments from Mike
Pence
later and you are going to want to beat
somebody up you will now now violence I
won't say violence never solves problems
because I mean look you know Israel um
in World War II but but violence won't
solve this problem with Mike Pence I
just warn you ahead of time it is so
infuriating uh it confirms every reason
that I've I've always very much disliked
him yes you were right couldn't put my
my my finger on it you're right from the
beginning well here's look here's what
they said the video that they put out
now this is not full video we'll get to
that one in just a second but here's
what is being put out from Des santis
trying to smear Trump and then two
nights ago I read all of Biden's
security people can you imagine National
Defense people and they said gee I hope
Hezbollah doesn't attack from the north
because that's the most vulnerable spot
I said wait a minute you know hezel is
very smart they're all very smart the
Press doesn't like when they say but
hezel they're very smart and they have a
National Defense Minister or somebody
saying I hope hezb doesn't attack us
from the north so the following morning
they attacked they might not have been
doing it but if you listen to this jerk
you would attack from the north because
he said that's our weak spot I'll never
forget that BB Netanyahu let us down
that was a very terrible thing I will
say that and uh so when I see sometimes
the intelligence you talk about the
intelligence or you talk about some of
the things that went wrong over the last
week uh they've got to straighten it out
because they're fighting potential a
very big Force they're fighting
potentially Iran oh okay so that makes
it look like he's calling out Benjamin
nahu during a time of war and saying
that they didn't get it right and
everything else he was actually
referring to what happened with Iran
when they got solaman and fried that guy
basically saying they ended up kind of
trying to take credit for it and then
saying hey you've really got to figure
this thing out because this is a very
serious situation but here's the tweet
that was included with that video from
Dan santis I'll read it for you
terrorists have murdered at least 1200
Israelis and 22 Americans and are
holding some hostage so it is absurd
that anyone much less someone running
for president would choose now to attack
our friend and Ally Israel much less
praise Hezbollah remember that he said
that that that sounds very familiar to
what we're going to talk about in a
minute praise Hezbollah terce say very
smart as president I will stand with
Israel and treat scum or terrorist like
the scum that they are before we move
before we move on here um let me ask you
this I'm and I'll make sure that that
way if this gets clipped uh that you
have 30 seconds in either direction okay
everyone here dislikes Hitler correct
everyone here
dis very very bad okay if I say Hitler
wasn't a dummy does that offend you does
that does that make you think that I
like Hitler hey if I say that uh for
example Putin's not a does that
does that offend you does that offend
you I I hate I hate Hitler not a fan of
Putin at all I I don't understand why
you're not allowed to objectively assess
by the way your opponent uh and and the
reason they do this is because they know
that the left will jump on and that's
what really bothers me when and and like
R if he is the candidate I'll vote for
him for president but they're are using
the Playbook kind of like uh Chris
Christie was at the debate he's Donald
Duck I'm GNA call you Donald Duck yeah
every 70-year-old watching was like
that's funny you're going to be dead
before voting sorry yeah I bet you
Donald Trump was like well watch me use
this cork screw
[Laughter]
Pettis
they have course crew penises and they
made for life cuz he can't pull them
apart now I'm going to duck you till you
love
me I duck you until you love me
Christie and the
leftwing the left wi media goes right on
to Echo this which is like oh boy were
they ready this is from Washington Post
I think you have Trump false Netanyahu
calls Hezbollah very smart amid Israel
war Politico says Netanyahu let us down
in quotes Trump chides Israel just days
after attack and then we have another
one here where is it from uh haret says
Trump slams Israel days after Hamas
attacks I'll never forget BB let us down
I mean come on right so here here's the
problem with all of that I told you this
quote from him sounds an awful lot like
the left right it's the same Playbook of
the left but they accidentally
apparently left some very important
parts of the speech out it's almost like
this has happened before where for
example remember when he said I'm not
talking about the white suprem neo-nazis
that need to be condemned totally
totally condemned
in Charlottesville remember when he said
that and then when he said make your
voices heard peacefully patriotically
and peacefully on January 6th they
completely eliminate that so when I see
people on the right you know what
comment below anyone bu anyone buy the
that Donald Trump hates Jews
doesn't like Israel I mean we'll get
into we have I feel like we almost don't
even need to build the case here and I'm
sure that Des santis would be a very
reasonable supporter of Israel in the
face of Terror just to be clear does
anyone actually buy that on Donald Trump
that's what bothers me is they know that
it's not true and they know the left is
going to pick it up anyway and just like
they pulled things out of context the
most important context Charlottesville
January 6th there's some context Here
video cont in the same speech in fact
video which means that DeSantis and his
people likely would have had access to
this right yes let's show some context
under my leadership the United States
will fully support Israel defeating
dismantling and permanently destroying
the terrorist group Hamas the state of
Israel is a blessing to the world our
prayers are with them now in this
terrible terrible time under my
leadership we will stand with Israel
100% And we will not let them
fail that that crystallize it for you so
he's not allow he's not allowed to say
that he's disappointed in Netanyahu
because of what happened with Iran who
by the way praised and took partially
took credit you know like Ben Affleck
with the Goodwill Hunting trip like I
toss my name on there that that that
whole
thing like he's saying we were
disappointed in that and by the way
considering how Trump can obviously
throw people on the bus this really
wasn't even bad no it has nothing to do
with his support for Israel which as a
matter of his policy will get into well
he's just probably saying like the
largest attack the largest loss of life
in Israel since the Holocaust it's
probably something to look into how it
happened okay if you're going to make
that case then obviously this is a big
failure the rest of the world was like
how did this happen to these guys so
it's not unreasonable for him to call it
out but look we're going to take a look
at some of the other lies the left and
even some on the right are trying to
spin about uh Donald Trump here Zion Don
as we have come to call him in the
office here I think it's I think it's an
AB Name by the way they did the same
thing with Co just so remember when he
said you know leaked in China and they
said he's he's being racist look stop
anti-asian hate they try to do the same
thing when Donald Trump uh said that
there you know liberal American Jews
weren't didn't share anything in common
with observant Jews right he said the
Jews love them and they said stop
anti-semitic it's on the rise under
Donald Trump so they try and take
something out of context then say on a
global scale this is the result of
Donald Trump but also he's a feckless
useless uh pseudo celebrity who no one
respects so take your pick but let's go
through the we'll go through the claims
here so here's claim number one for you
right Trump reveres dictators and
terrorists America doesn't stand with
thugs and dictators we confront them or
at least we used to there can be no room
in the leadership of the Republican
party for apologist for Putin it can
only be r for champion of Freedom
weakness arouses evil Pence says well I
guess that explains this a cat couldn't
scratch when Satan is
around was such a poor choice of words
arouses arouses that guy hasn't been
aroused in years evil I am saying that
uncertainty
titillates Bad
Karma I I don't understand
thisy evil is suckling at the teeth yes
of
Freedom they also say idiocy arouses
evil in which case run AOC beyb must be
raging in his pants now thank you for
cleaning that
quote movie line so that's the claim
that is the claim well hold on before we
get before we get to the truth here just
do me a favor drop a like if you want
Mike Pence to just walk off the stage
into the sunset and never be heard from
again I think most of us here would be
completely happy with that happening but
look who is giving that man money who
stop it you know what's funny is I
forget about him I know I forget until I
see I'm like oh yeah Mike Pence is but
somewhere people are giving millions of
dollars to his pack it's probably some
like lady named Ethel who sees him in
her Facebook he a
spunk I like the cut of his jib he a
funny all right so the claim is that he
reveres and loves dictators and teris
all right bring up the truth to truth
calling somebody smart is not actually
praising them we' point that out with
Hitler right so despite saying that
Putin is smart I'll go through some of
the examples here yeah Hitler bad thank
you hit Hitler bad Hitler bad go Hitler
bad not an idiot sorry guys not an idiot
bad guy not an idiot so never a bad time
for that Stinger despite ever by the way
ever heard the term Evil Genius I know
you hear the term genius but the first
part is
evil go it's almost like it defines the
rest
of so look he said Putin was smart they
called him out for that immediately
right but here's what he did he actually
pulled out of the missile agreement with
uh Russia he broke that agreement Israel
uh actually he increased us oil
production which actually hurt isra
Russia and its allies Y and allegedly
threatened to Nuke Moscow turn it to
Glass yeah uh if they invaded Ukraine
and did they invade Ukraine under Donald
Trump I'm they did not no they didn't
okay so listen he is somewhat crazy we
believe he will do what he says actually
do it uh we might just for when people
I'm sorry sorry again Hitler bad just so
you know Hitler bad but not an ID like
again Evil Genius pinky in the brain
right they were trying to take over the
world every day it doesn't happen
without the brain if the brain wasn't
there we're not saying he's not trying
to take over the it would just be
pinky yeah can you imagine if the Allies
had assumed that Hitler was not smart
right exactly if they had just been like
oh he's an idiot we'll take care of this
and we'll be done with this by 1941 what
are we going to do tomorrow night adol
same thing we do every night pinky try
to exterminate the
Jews
Gerald you're
B silly G to let that one
ride all right so let's let's focus on
China now you can do the Chinese voice
if you likees the Shing ping uh he said
he was smart he actually launched a
trade war against China and he banned
the Chinese Corporation huawe even
though it's not spelled like that and
that pisses me off almost more than
anything else he approved billions of
dollars in sales to uh or for arm sales
to Taiwan and also do you remember the
thing with Tik Tok we he tried to ban
Tik Tok he tried to make them divest and
have a US company buy them but that was
in I think August of 2020 and by the
time the election rolled around didn't
have time to finish it but I guarantee
you Tik Tok would look a little bit
different if Donald Trump were still
president okay so uh we've got two cases
right now completely blown out of the
water and then our resident fat boyin
Chief over there in North Korea Kim
Jong-un he actually said he was smart as
well I think that was a lie I don't
think he did no I think he was trolling
I think he's trolling him a little bit
let's be honest okay again that's the
problem with trump it doesn't read the
same like if you read like and then he
and then he said Kim Jong-un is so smart
yes he is very smart I can't get over
how smart he is you would read it but
really like and and then I said Kim Zago
is so smart he's so I can't get over how
smart he is right just laughing it's
like he has nothing else good to say
about him he's like uh he's uh he's
smart and uh he looks handsome and he's
smart did I say that already did I say
that he has to breathe through his mouth
like a bulldog that's cute I guess I
think it's cuz he's so fat we'll show
you a video of that by the way but Trump
threatened you've heard of sleep apnea
this man has all the time apnea when
he's awake almost stops breathing
someone get this Vick Veo all
right so Trump threatened fire and fury
if North Korea attacked the United
States He also said this about Kim your
quote why would actually you have to
read the quote why would Kim Jun insult
me by calling me old when I would never
call him short and fat
folks oh well I try so hard to be his
friend and maybe someday that will
happen I've always needed a short and
fat friend I love how he's like I would
never call him short and fat yeah and by
the way he actually did insult him to
his face yeah very ni getting a good
picture everybody so we look nice and
handsome and thin beautiful
watch when the translation hits him
huh look at this
guy he just called me fat what are you
going to do about it un do something
dude nothing all right so moving on to
Iran so despite saying that the Iranian
leaders are again smart he actually
pulled out of the Iran deal and he Fric
AED solaman yeah exactly just to come on
like is there any doubt what he's doing
with this he's acknowledging the
opponent has some intellect and skill
and you have to combat that that's it
he's not saying why I should be like
that guy anyone who believes that Donald
Trump likes Kim Jong-un or likes for
example the leaders of Iran um well you
know I'm I don't believe that anyone
believes that no okay just I just think
it's dishonest and that's what really
rubs me the wrong way about DeSantis
about Pence because they have echoed
what the left has used and I don't think
that they believe it I do not think that
they believe for one second that Donald
Trump is anti-israel I don't know you
comment below try to not uh attribute
any kind of motives I just can't see
someone actually buying that especially
considering all the criticism that he
has endured for being too aggressive of
a supporter of Israel for being too
bullish on the Iran deal right Barack
Obama Biden said he was going to
destabilize the Middle East by by by
isolating Iran and now it's I just I'm
sorry I just don't buy it I just don't
buy it but the media is all too happy to
run with these Headlines by the way I've
been watching the CNN kind of Chiron
that they have down there and earlier in
the show they were talking about this
earlier in the show they were talking
about the claims that Rona santis is
leveling you can see who's carrying the
water for Ronda santis when he's putting
out an edited video but that's not the
only claim let me bring you to another
claim really quickly here that Donald
Trump is an anti-semite yeah okay here
we go let me read some quotes for you
about how Donald Trump might be an
anti-semite here we go Trump uses
anti-semitic tropes to again criticize
Jewish Americans by way these are
through the time this doesn't
necessarily mean today but it's a claim
L this what they've said about him that
Trump goes full anti-semite unloads on
American Jews in wildly bigoted rant and
another one Donald Trump continues his
long history of pushing anti-semitic
tropes it's almost like you use the same
kind of headline is the first guy the
truth
original Trump is the most Pro Am
pro-israel American president in history
by the way before we get to Clips sorry
I had to interrupt you but you know how
you know it's true how all the actual
like neo-nazis hated Donald Trump
because of this just to be clear look at
people who actually actually hate Israel
they were furious with Donald Trump yeah
they did not like him at all and that
should be the first thing that you
should look for for somebody who's
anti-semitic if if you piss off Nazis
right if you piss off Nazis you're
probably not an anti-semite I I think
that's probably a good place to start
May 2017 Donald Trump became the first
president to go and prey at the Western
Wall also known as The Wailing Wall and
we have the
footage
[Applause]
actually um you know that's it's great
that we've had that footage but we
actually have some exclusive audio of
what he was saying during that prayer so
here watch this dear God you know who it
is it's the best Christian even though I
know I'm at the Jewish place the wall
that frankly is a great wall I love the
Jews too
I'm a Christian but I also like Jews I
really like their walls I like their
matzah so God I'm here in Jerusalem with
a lot of Jews and you know what that
means it's getting pretty bad out here
very that's what people say it's getting
really bad it's sad all this with the
Jews Hamas the idiots and the it's
terrible but you know look we don't talk
all the time but I have a Bible I have a
great everyone talks about how I have
the best Bible it's laminated okay
that's practical I get it by the way
you're you fun you help support this
through you know mug club we have an
investigative journalist uh with mics on
him all the time well up in heaven oh
that's right yeah have a direct line
we so join mug Club to keep heaven in
operation he's an anti-semite he's an
anti-semite who was he moved the United
States right there their Israeli Embassy
to Jerusalem to Jerusalem and you got to
read the quote again I'm Donald Trump
because you know today we finally
acknowledge the obvious Jerusalem is
Israel's capital I mean that's pretty
easy right that is kind of in their name
yes and that is poking their finger
poking his finger in the chess chest of
Hamas just to be clear and other
presidents have talked about this and
never on it Donald Trump talked about it
and then made it happened December of
2018 as well Trump approved the largest
ever Aid package uh to Israel that seems
like a a pretty pro-israel stance March
of 2019 Trump became the first president
to recognize the Goen Heights as Israeli
ter territory and then also June 2019 we
could go through a lot of these well he
did that and and basically as a sign of
gratitude Israel actually named an
entire new city yeah after president
Trump and
see
I always find it a little bit unsettling
when I know he's I know he's speaking
obviously in Hebrew but it sounded like
he said himler it really
did um it was by the way it was so
successful the Israeli tourism board
they even created an ad for the newly
named
City tra
[Music]
trites it's the best is what everybody
else says I think it's the same slogan
writer it's yo
play it is so
good that's their SL great slogans it's
it's to the point
right but he also he has some really
ambitious plans for Gaza when all of
this kind of oh that's right he does
yeah so if it seems like we're being
silly today it's because this is silly
goofy crap for people to say oh Donald
Trump is anti-Semitic for Rhonda s say
oh he's now he's now actually attacking
our allies and praising just shut there
is come on this deserves no Credence but
I feel like we need to come here and and
give you the information that you need
because you're probably sitting there
going all right this come on it's it's
I'm not buying this but you need to be
able to substantiate it it's absurd and
it's about to anger you just a little
more cuz we're going to get to the Pence
clip but here's another claim Trump did
or will cause chaos in the Middle East
and this is where we have on Sunday Mike
Pence blaming Trump for blaming Trump
for the terrorist attacks it's clip
Pence dumb yep but I also believe this
is what happens when we have leading
voices like Donald Trump VC Ram Swami
and Ronda santis signaling Retreat from
America's role as leader of the Free
World stop giving that man
money whoever is doing it whoever is
giving tense money just stop it's like
Donald Trump pulling back from the rest
now this happened under Donald Trump by
the way you were vice president during
that time and he took credit for that as
at the debates on that at the debates
what you talking about we had two Peace
Accords just can someone like can
someone just give that man a swirly put
him in a locker something it's time for
him to go okay so here's the actual
truth Trump brought unprecedented
stability to the Middle East right so he
actually broker the uh what is it called
oh yeah Abraham Accords which saw
multiple Islam Islamic countries read
that as countries who typically hate the
Jews they recognized Israel for the
first time the UAE Bahrain Morocco Sudan
those are that's pretty good deal right
so Saudi Arabia Israeli relations were
improving under Trump that's also a
really tough bar for them to get over
and the the Israeli flights are allowed
to actually Transit Saudi Arabian
airspace now doesn't sound like much but
that's a big deal when you're at the
same time while he was brokering peace
with some of he was also cracking down
on Nations that still in other words
they were given a chance like you want
to give p a chance to find oh you still
want to wipe Israel off the face of the
map and fund terrorism then we're going
to come down on you hard right he was
the one who actually withdrew from the
Iran deal it's the the JC POA I'm not
going to go and uh the sanctions by the
way really did crippling they were CRI
they were crippling to the Iranian
economy less money from oil Revenue
right they had you remember that $6
billion dollar that was frozen yep who
do you think froze it who yeah and who
was criticized for freezing it exactly
right and now you unfreeze it all of a
sudden terum starts happening again and
then you're thinking like oh man we
should have got frozen yeah yeah have we
have this from Washington Post in the
hill because I know we're we're going
late but you can look at again Barack
Obama and you can look at Biden the the
the billions of dollars pallets of cash
pallets of cash lit pallets of actual
cash which is how I imagine people are
funding Mike Pence's campaign I have no
idea how that man has money sending it
to Iran pallets of cash like do it in
gift cards like just just for Optics
sake yeah for Lowe's yeah exactly and
for we we only have Home Depot
that's why we gave you loow yeah we love
it look and for for everybody out there
who who thinks okay well fine maybe
you've made that case for him but he
doesn't have a plan for peace in the
middle oops he does right so he actually
proposed a plan that would bring peace
to both Israel and to Palestine and it
had support by the UAE Saudi Arabia and
even Egypt right now I don't fully trust
them to be clear understand that I agree
but it's better than thousands of
inocent dead hey what uh what plan has
Biden proposed that has support from
multiple countries that have in the the
past wanted to drive the Israelites into
the sea pallets of cash for the Iranians
that well that actually that goes the
other way sir that actually supports the
terrorism angle so well then I don't
have anything you don't have anything
because there is nothing and by the way
look we'll we'll dive into this a little
bit more tomorrow we're going to do a
geopolitics slash uh um what is it uh
jald the Apologetics one I always
apologize as AP because it ties in with
Israel and the Jews yeah so we're going
to talk about that and how it's
impossible to be Christian and to be
anti-semitic at the same time it's weird
because the Bible is like I don't know
mostly about Jewish people and also
Christians we could craft it in hey yeah
yes right but here's the thing do you
think comment below do you think a a
two-state solution is even possible do
you think that would solve the problems
here or do you think that they're going
to find another way to be a thorn in
Israel's side from here until Kingdom
Come by the way look I understand that
even though the Middle East was not
perfect under Donald Trump at least it's
a lot better than what you see going on
right
now warning to people watching
Afghanistan
withdrawal Iran and Saudi Arabia are to
resumed diplomatic relations in a deal
brokered by China which took the World
by surprise it's been welcomed across
the Middle East and internationally but
not in
Israel abib that's the wrong way
Habib I don't no I watch I watch knees
over toes guy I go backwards it balances
the quadr I have muscle
imbalance you have no muscle well we do
eat sand he's practicing running
away no I'm leaving I know I love the
guy with the RPG in the gym in the gym
sure you should put some weights on each
side and just start squat I'm doing RPG
isometrics oh they it's a static hold
the whole place just blows up I'm like
Alexander Lou old strong man they know
what they're doing it's functional these
people suck my point is look is that the
deadlift that's also they're swimming
it's a dead man's Flo well they can't
they can't puppy paddle cuz dogs are
awful over there they hate them I don't
care how you want to spin
this um no actually I do let me okay
there's no way to spin this there's no
way to spin this as though Donald Trump
is uh is anti-Semitic there's also by
the way we've talked about the economy
okay Russia under Donald Trump let me
let me go back even further remember
when John McCain was running for office
and at that point George W Bush was not
very popular and so when George W bush
kind of gave him his endorsement he was
like well thank you keep that to
yourself you
know because it's still was sort of okay
you didn't want to go after and attack
you know sort of the Republican who was
there before you sort of an Unwritten
agreement but generally speaking it
wasn't a good political strategy so this
is the guy whether you like him or not
Donald Trump was president he's the last
Republican president who we've we've had
and now you have everyone and I don't
just mean something you have everyone
else aside from VC really at this point
um maybe Tim Scott attacking Donald
Trump and that would be one thing if he
truly was an awful person that was he
was worthy of an attack we've already
gone through the economy but for
Republicans now to be attacking Donald
Trump on Israel in the Middle East
when just as far as political expediency
I don't know who their handlers are it
would be pretty easy to say hey hey I'm
not running against Donald Trump as a
whether you're D santis whoever I'm
running against Joe Biden and you know
what for all of the things that Donald
Trump said or did and uh when there was
a republican in the White House at least
Russia didn't invade Ukraine as they did
under Obama and under Biden least
Afghanistan was somewhat stable as
opposed to having pallets of cash and
Apache helicopters North Korea was
pretty damn quiet and you know what for
the first time in any uh modern
president's history no new wars were
started that's a pretty easy sell and so
when I see people like Dan santis and
people like Pence and Christie coming
out and attacking Donald Trump for
things on which they know he's right if
you want to come out and attack him for
Mean Tweets you want to Sure fine you
just can't do it here as far as the
stability in the Middle East he can't do
it as far as not supporting Israel if
you hate that Donald Trump was too
robust in supporting Israel you can say
that you can be the libertarian
candidate who attacks him on that front
but when you say that you Israel
harder you're full of and you guys
can comment below it's just it's just to
me when when I see a completely
disingenuous attack on someone yeah
that's when I go oh this is a pile up
and we see it happen yeah well he's
looking for any angle that he can find
right now Mr Ronda santis down 40 points
is yeah in the primary look I get it
again if Ronda santis becomes the
nominee I like Ronda santis enough to
vote for him for president I absolutely
would support him I don't think that's
going to happen but look you got to do
it in an honorable way you have to get
there the right way otherwise it doesn't
matter if you get there you cannot go
after Republicans the way that the left
goes after Republicans yeah you have a
problem with him point out that problem
what you just did edited a video
selectively and put it out there to try
to to to smear him when the proof is
just piled up over time he didn't say it
I know you were a governor and that's a
big deal but he didn't just say it he
did it other people said it and never
did it Donald Trump delivered in this
area stay off of him in this area
otherwise you have no hope of getting
there and by the way if you stay on him
in this area I don't want you anywhere
near the white house because it just
means you're going to do whatever you
have to do to get what you want and by
the way we also we also criticized
Donald Trump when he did this with Ronda
sanos on coov yeah he tried to say and
you know it's wrong with Co and that's
just been wrong about a lot of stuff
about a lot of stuff he was wrong for
calling out some of those politicians
and laughing at people losing it's like
he's wrong for telling people not to
vote in Georgia for the senate race he
was like I wouldn't even vote in it he's
wrong for doing those things we said hey
he's wrong for endorsing Dr Oz yes he's
not wrong for hating the Jews or doing a
poor job in the Middle East he's not
wrong for any of those things because
it's the opposite of that and this is
what gaslighting is this is what people
who have no semblance of even even a
remote responsibility to truth and I'm
not saying that that is DeSantis I'm not
but what I am saying is that's a lot of
these handlers when people say it's just
a game I don't mean all that Republicans
and Democrats are the same no no they're
actually not I I'm precluded I will be
clear I precluded from from voting for
anyone in the DNC today just so you know
I'm a conservative I don't vote for
anyone just because they have an R next
to their name but I will not vote for
anyone who has a d next to their name
yep you can call me you can call that
tribalism comment below if you have a
problem with it that being said when you
have people on the right who are just
looking to score
points at the cost of the American
people that's when I think you're
disingenuous and that that's what I'm
seeing with these attacks and that's why
I want by the end of
today uh Mike Pence to be
penniless pantless yes no pant for you
penniless pantless and homeless and
pantsless too well in said Satan take
this man's pants each their own you were
a little he's aroused you were very very
zealous about that so uh all right I
think do you have anything I think we've
covered it I think we've just by the way
Josh thank you for your service you'll
be at M October 13th this Friday make a
mess with me freaky maybe it's one of
those things maybe if there's a
thunderstorm you'll get to switch bodies
with Jessie that day freaky Jesse Messy
Jessie and you get to be you get to be
all Parkinson's Jesse so uh if
you're if you're watching on YouTube
right now there's nothing you can do but
if you're watching on Rumble just click
that button and you get to continue
watching for another 45 minutes to an
hour depending how long it goes it is
going to be chat Thursday Rumble thank
you very much the people of Israel uh
obviously our our hearts are with you uh
right now I can't even imagine what it
is that you're going through YouTube
piss
off